anymore Peters and stuff coming up oh
yeah yeah of course then with Peterson I
mean I was saying this to it to his wife
it's like when you're making music and
writing and stuff often times you quote
the Great's
and you know you quote a hunter of
Samson or you quote young or whatever
but they're all dead you know knew they
didn't they were audio if there are
audio recordings of them they're not
very good and there aren't that many of
them and here we have Peterson like
spitting napalm on a daily basis
like dropping like hours of audio every
day it's all brilliant all
incredibly quotable and it's also
incredibly sonorous musical and
beautiful and important and necessary
right now if I did nothing else in my
life even if I didn't even eat I could
just sit there making Peterson music
forever because there's so much material
so I will continue to make Peterson
stuff and it will continue to be useful
when there's also many many other things
to draw into music and make useful in
that fashion it's basically it appears
to be a new genre or at least a new way
of sort of communicating ideas and stuff
and I've always done it I've always made
mixtapes that brought in people talking
and bringing in ideas and made it
musical we're just like now there's a
real big appetite for it and thanks to
those lovely robots over at YouTube it's
just this expanding universe of
potential for people actually wanting to
listen to it and being able to do it
there will be a JD Peterson low fire
onra well there is well I mean you're
the only one so well no other people are
doing it now if you go if you go look it
up there's actually loads of people
doing it now
- like varying degrees of sort of
success but lots of people are doing it
and I've been doing you know it with
other things and it's it's called
meaning wave now someone called it that
and of course there is a there is a
there was a genre it's now yeah it's a
thing it's called meaning wave it
combines music aesthetics of low firing
vaporwave and very for trapping and
cloud wrap and with meaningful spoken
stuff so it's not just Peterson know
it's now just it's kind of like the
intellectual darkweb thing I guess but
with music
don't struggle for power that isn't what
men do
not if they're civilized besides each
other up and elect the confident to lead
and they do that at every level of
society I worked in rail crew in
southern Saskatchewan they're rough guys
like a lot of them have been in prison
you know and he first came onto the rail
crew he got a stupid nickname and people
T is DD and I remember this one kid
called lunch box box that was his
nickname cuz he came to the real crew
with a lunch bucket that looked like his
mom and acted that that was a bad idea
so they need to lunch bucket which he
wasn't very happy about well that was a
mistake he should have taken it with the
smile and then he was always be that she
narrative moment if he asked him to do
something he why was about 60 men on
this crew stretcher quarter mile down
the tracks soon anonymous Colossus were
throwing pebbles at him during work we
had hard out so on so the game was let's
see if we can hit a lunch bucket in the
get my heart out with a pebble and then
that was purposeful because he didn't
couldn't take a joke so I pull let's see
if he can take this chill
[Music]
and then it just got more and more
peevish and that the pebbles got bigger
bigger they are bigger in manners
[Music]
was gone have they learned anything from
the experience but you know when an
alert has to come out it's like can you
take a joke can you be useful
can you at least be amusing is there
something worthwhile about you
[Music]
but no it's like okay well then you're
outta here because you never know when
we actually might need to depend on you
[Music]